taxi driver was my first script and I
wrote that as self therapy I was in a a
kind of a dark place drinking and
driving I didn't have a place to live I
had a gun in the car I had a pain in my
stomach went to the hospital had a
bleeding ulcer at the age of 25. and I
realized in an emergency room that I
hadn't spoken to anybody in weeks and in
the hospital I got this image of the
taxi cab it came to me this yellow
rectangular metal coffin floating
through the open sewers of a metropolis
with this boy trapped inside who can't
get out who looks like he's in a crowd
but he's desperately alone and I said
that's who I am I'm the kid in that cab
and so I realized that it was time I had
to turn to fiction in order to get out
of this place I had to create this
character or else I was going to become
him and that character was Travis Bickle
as I wrote about him he became more and
more detached for me I learned about
that young man and I learned not to be
that young man by writing about it so I
walked into the whole screenwriting
business as self-therapy not as Commerce